M: Wait, who's? Is it- is it just me and Bob right now?
B: Is it a 1v1?
M: It's a face-off!
It's a fucking face-off.
J: We got a face-off, face-off
M: We got a face-off!
J: Clear the crowd, clear the crowd, make room.
M: I got my sniffer ready. I'm gonna hunt you down Bob. Just like the-
Oooh! A computer mouse.. are you?
B: You know, I did try and become the computer mouse, but turns out--
M: That you succeeded, and then I'm gonna hunt you down like the rat you are
M: Wait a minute
B: Uhum
Jack: Oh ohh ohh
Bob: Nope nope nope
(intense yelling and shooting from Mark)
*Wade laughs*
B: We're fine... sniff my butthole..
J: The sniffers working
M: My sniffers!
Mark:  Really sniffed'em out there!
W: How is stuff already knocked over? We just spawned in!
Mark: Mmmhhnnn??
Bob: Oh no...
Bob: I wonder where you are, stuff knocker over
*laughs*
J: Haha.. Wait..
M: You got him good
B: I got your number now.
B: Ah! it's just this error for me. You just carry around a big error.
J: I‘m carrying a giant error!
BEWAAARREEE
W: It's a really long auto rifle like the clip going into the top
M: Woooaaaaow.
B: How can you see it?!
J: Aaaahhh I know what you're trying to do
M: Wait.. What kind of game do you need to get that?
Wade: Do you guys have it? We didn't checked everything to make sure you guys have all the games and stuff.
Mark: I DM'd all of you being like "Heuyy chek awt da-- to make shure you have th-- ..
..Ehhoor-urrgheurvuaorgh!!
*Followed by laughter*
B: I got you back dude
J: Make sure you have the BLUEAGHUHU
M: Sorry I just had to vomit at that moment
*slow motion vomit*
M: there was no hesitation on that grenade I didn't even get to barter
B: I mean I saw.. I saw the plant and I was like--
B: Yeah, I think that‘s him
Bob: I think we all know that needs to happen.
M: Wait a minute, wait, wait. Wade, Wade turn around Wade. Wade turn around Wade.
..Ah you missed it it was there I swear.
Bob: Oh no!! The timer! I forgot about the timer!
Mark: *between laughs* I've seen thah-ahaha-aath--
Bob: *inaudible*
M: There was a rogue bucket. There's a rogue bucket that was bouncing behind your head
Bob: Na-Nah. It's fine, it's fine don't worry about it
Jack: We're good, we're good. We're goochi. We're goochi
B: It‘s fine, don‘t worry about it
M: Cut'em off! Cut'em off!
B: Don't worry about it, it's fine.
M: Did you cut'em off?
M: .. Wade, you idiot. Cut'em off...
W: I‘ve never seen this bucket!
W: I don't believe there's a bucket!
M: Wade there‘s a bucket! I'm not crazy. There's a bucket.
Bob: Mark is... Mark's just insane
Mark: Nno.
Wade: Where's the *bleep* bucket
M: Wait a minute
B: No, no no it‘s fine! Don‘t worry about it.
M: Wade come back. Circle around
B: It's fine, it's fine.
B: Yes Wade come back
J: Where the FUCK are you?
M: Aaaagghhh I almost hit you
Bob: I'm definitely real Wade, don't worry
Wade: I don't believe in this bucket!
Mark: There was a bucket!
J: Where are you guys?
W: I don‘t see a bucket again!
Mark: Oh come on, Wade. Jeez, man.
W: I don't know how you keep losing this imaginative bucket!
M: There was a bucket, and it was mobile.
W: Oh hey a bucket. I found a bucket!
M: Is it dead?
B: No! No! No, no, no, let's talk about this. I'll show you where Jack is!
M: Wade? Wade!
B: I'm right here, I'm the bucket
M: That was my bucket kill...
W: No no no, I found this bucket
M: No that was the same bucket I was running after
B: Wait wait wait, you guys—
B: You guys want to fight over the kill I have an idea
B: I'm gonna hop over here. W: okay?
B: And then you guys go out there. It's a shooting gallery M: Okay?
M: Ohh. A shotgun
W: Hey, I picked the best one—
M: Awww
W: WHO GOT THE KILL?
M: You didn't even believe in the bucket, okay? I was the one who
W: You didn‘t believe in the shotgun!
W: wHo'S LaUgHiNg nOw???2?
W: GUN ENTHUSIAST!
M: *dies with laughter*
B: Is your gun full of poop?
B: The shit blaster!
M: MMMM
M: There's a lot of suspiciously placed stuff that I don't remember being that way
J: Aha!
J: I'm using your own stupidity against you!
M: No! My one weakness!
J: I keep hearing shots in the distance, but I don't—I haven't seen anyone
B: I don't understand how this worked. I don't understand how you did this
B: Also, I don't understand why it worked
M: I don't like this
J: I told you Bob, own stupidity against them! (Mark no you just passed him)
M: *caveman grunting*
B: You‘re a godamn wizard, that‘s what you are
M: *stupid voice* stupidness isn't weakness. We stupidness is strength
J: Me brain are big strong
M: *laughs*
B: I'm less optimistic that this is gonna work, but if it does
J: I mean there's 20 seconds left
B: You‘re a goddamn genius
M: Ooooh Wade! Combine our brain power, we am think through!
W: I am combining so hard right now
M: OOOOH
W: I'm stuck in the window!
M: *high pitched* Where is he?!
W: ARGHHH
M: WHERE IS HE?
B: He was that file cabinet!
W: DAMN ITTT!!!
J: I was literally right here.
M: What what? Where?!
W: DAMN IT!!
M: Aah, that‘s bullshit!
W: WE SUCK!
J: I don't feel like I deserved that
M: I don't feel like you deserve it either
W: You could've come out at any time
M: Yeah, you could've come out uh *mumbles*
M: *clears throat*
B: Wh-what?
J: There's a bin missing I know that for factoid
M: You don't know that for a fact
J: There was a bin right here, cause I sat next to it before
M: I'm pretty sure if you do a count of all the bins in the office
M: You'll find that there are exactly the number of bins that there should be
J: Which is how many?
M: Eh uh I DON'T KNOW WHY DON'T YOU ANSWER
B: Hey douchebags, where are you?
M: You know: around, next to you, in front of you, around you
M:  i n s i d e  y o u
M: I still haven‘t moved! I still haven‘t moved!
M: I've been a GOOD boy! I haven't moved. *sings* You are my sunshine, my only sunshine—
W: AHHHHHHHH
W: Come on!
W: I was paper towels by the door!
M: Ohh, I don't even think you guys get to deserve to know what I was, 'cause I was very in the open
J: Were you a bucket?
M: No I wasn't, I tried a lot of things and I was like
M: Heh, I'll do this thing that no one will know. I was a plant in the room where you shot every plant except for me
M: So that worked out incredibly well for me
M: Wade, let's be very focused about this. Okay, pay very close attention
B: That‘s feeling smoky delicious
W: Can we get a four minute clue?
M: Yeah
B: This is like uh, smoked—smoked shack almonds.
M: Smoke? Okaaay....
B: No my eyes hurt from all the particulates from the smoke
M: You guys should be aware, it's a
M: NON-SMOKING OFFICE!
Health code regulation state: you are assholes!
B: *laughs*
B: Is that our punishment for smoking?
W: Hey, why is there a chair—
B: Hey hey this is a non-smoking room
B: Just for smoking, you're an asshole!
M: *laughs*
M: Yeah, doesn't it seem like an appropriate punishment?
W: Detective Mark, I noticed a flipped over chair.
M: Ahh...how suspicious
J: *mockingly* Oh no!
J:  J'accuse! [French for "I accuse"] They are on the trail
M: Alright
W: AHA!
M: AHA!
M: Where were you on the night of the seventh?
W: Uh, I fed Mark the whole time
J: Right now it's the night of the seventh
M: I know!
M: Oh wait
J: Right here!
J: MURDERER!
J: Turns out he shoots you, like, "I knew you'd be here on the day of my murder!"
M and B: *laughs*
M: Wait, Wade? Did you break down this back window?
W: Yes.
M: Oh, okay. Never mind.
M, B, J: *laughs*
M: J'accuse! [French for "I accuse"] I KNEW it was you!
J: If you guys want to find us, you better "handle with care"
M: Wait...
W: They're milk.
*Everyone laughing at Wade being stupid*
J: I mean, I guess
J: We could be a fucking...TV or something!
B: Alright Wade, if you keep guessing like that I‘ll give you as many clues as you want
B: Well okay okay in fairness in fairness
B: We are smoke and/or a smoke-like object
M: A pipe! Vape!
M: They're vapes
W: Coffee? Coffee? Smoke... Steam..
J: There hookah pipes
M: Salmon! Smoked salmon!
J: Chimney! Chimney!
B: Wait wait wait Jack I've got one that will not help them at all
J: Okay
W: Okay
B: What we are, we're kind of the same thing, and uh, I ship us
M: THEY‘RE A BOAT!
J: Yeah, I'd ship us together
B: Yeah. W: Chip?
J: Yeah, just be "fragile" with our relationship though
M: They're lead-based paint! They chip! And you eat it! And you get smarter
J: SHIP!
M: Chip
J: What gets shipped?
W: I think ship is the clue...
J: One of you is very close.
B: One of you is an idiot
J: One of you just ran past
M: *markiplier noises
B: Nope. you‘re still an idiot.
J: Go back to that room!
*Mark getting angry over his stupidity*
W: It wasn't me, it was you
J: We‘re boxes on the shelf!
*Intense screaming as he realises how stupid he was*
M: Ah, I get it! Box, smoke. I get it!
*Whaaaat?!?! face*
J: Fragile! Handle with care
M: *laughs*
*outro song*
Subtitles by Claire and others!
Have a fab day!
*outro song ends*